- [Voiceover] I have two water
molecules right over here,
and typically the water molecules, as they
interact with each other,
they form these hydrogen bonds
that's due to the polarity
of the water molecule.
We've talked a lot about that, they slide
past each other, these
hydrogen bonds give them
all these neat properties of water.
But chemistry is much
messier, than sometimes
our diagrams or explanations show.
There's all sorts of crazy interactions.
All of these things are bumping
into each other in all different ways.
And not only are the molecules bumping
in different ways, but any given moment,
the electrons are jumping around and,
on average, they might spend more time,
they might spend more
time around the oxygen
forming a partially
negative charge at that end,
and then a partially positive charge near
the hydrogens, because the
hydrogens are having their
electrons hogged away from them.
In fact this is what
forms the hydrogen bonds.
But there's always
constantly change there.
Because they're all just jumping around.
It's all very probabilistic.
And so you can imagine, under
just the right conditions,
one oxygen or one water
molecule, might just
graze this water molecule
in the right way,
that these electrons,
get close enough to nab,
to nab this hydrogen.
But it doesn't nab the entire hydrogen.
It doesn't nab the
nucleus and the electron,
and a typical hydrogen atom,
a typical hydrogen atom,
actually let me draw it.
A typical hydrogen atom is just a proton,
is just a proton in the nucleus.
Actually the most typical
isotope of hydrogen
has no neutron, so it's just
a proton in the nucleus.
And an electron orbiting around it.
So this right over here is positive,
actually maybe I'll draw it that way,
you have a positive
proton, and then you have
a negative electron, you
have a negative electron
orbiting around it.
Actually it's more of a orbital.
So it's really this electron
is jumping all around it.
But you could imagine,
these electrons in this
covalent bond, they were already being,
these we already being hogged,
these were already being
hogged by this oxygen,
in fact that's what was forming this
partial negative charge over here,
and the partial positive charge over here.
So these would be attracted to this
partial positive charge.
Remember there, you
have a partial negative
charge over here, this is
actually what's forming
the hydrogen bond.
And it actually could bond
to the hydrogen proton,
while both of these
electrons, including one
of these electrons that used to be part of
this hydrogen, or you could consider
used to be part of that hydrogen,
are nabbed, are nabbed by this oxygen.
And in this circumstance,
and I'm not saying
that this happens all the time,
but under just the right conditions, this
actually can happen,
and what would result,
so let me, what result is, this thing
over here, instead of just being a neutral
water molecule, would look like this.
So you have your oxygen, you have,
not only your two hydrogens now,
you now have a third hydrogen.
You now have a third hydrogen.
So you have these two covalent bonds,
these two covalent bonds, this lone pair.
And now this lone pair,
which I have circled in blue,
is now being shared with
this hydrogen proton.
This electron right over
here of the hydrogen
got nabbed by this oxygen.
So now you've formed
another covalent bond.
And now this character over here,
he's lost the hydrogen proton, but he's
kept all of the electrons.
So this character over
here's gonna look like this.
You're gonna have your oxygen,
and now it's only going to only be bonded
to one hydrogen, only
bonded to one hydrogen.
Has these two original lone pairs.
These two original lone
pairs right over here.
And then took both of the electrons
from this covalent bond.
And took both of the electrons
And so it has another lone pair.
So this molecule gained just a proton
without getting any electrons.
So if you do that, you're
now going to have a
net positive charge
for this one over here.
And this molecule over
here, actually let me,
let me, ugh, let me just write it.
I wanna write it a little bit neater.
And this molecule over here, so we have
this molecule plus this one, this one
lost a proton, without any other changes.
So it now has a negative charge.
So just like that, you
went from two neutral
water molecules, to two ions.
And these ions, this one over here,
the one on the left, the one that is now
H three O, H three O, H three O,
and it now has a positive charge,
positive charge, actually I put that O
in a different color.
H three, H three O.
It's a positive charge, this
is called the "hydronium ion."
Hydronium, hydronium.
And this one over here, that is OH minus,
so it's OH, O, let me
get the colors right.
OH minus.
This is called the
"hydroxide ion," or since
it's negative you can
just call it an "anion."
I'll just write "hydroxide," hydroxide,
hydroxide ion right over there.
So you have this water
and it's just kind of
automatically under the
right circumstances,
this isn't happening a lot, but under the
right circumstances, you could have one
of the water molecules nabbing just
the hydrogen proton, from
another water molecule.
And that water molecule
is gonna keep both of the
electrons, and then they ionize.
They have autoionized,
and this phenomenon,
this is called "the
autoionization of water."
Let me write that down,
it's a nice big word.
Autoionization.
Autoionization of, of water.
And I really want to make
it clear what happens.
This hydrogen over here,
that you can imagine
at first was a proton and an electron,
the typical isotope of hydrogen actually
does not have a neutron.
But then this electron got swiped.
This electron, this electron
was part of this bond
and it gets swiped away, and so all you're
left is with this proton, and this proton
goes to this other water molecule,
giving that a positive charge.
And so you might say,
"Well how frequently would
"I find hydronium ions in water?"
Well the concentration,
let me actually draw
a little tub of water
here, let's say this is a
liter of water.
This is a liter, this is a liter of water.
The concentration of
hydronium in typical water,
the concentration of H three O,
the concentration of H
three O in typical water,
and you put brackets around something
to denote "concentration," is
one times ten to the negative seven molar.
And molar, this just
means "moles per liter."
This is the same thing as
one times ten to the negative seven moles,
moles per liter.
And now you might be saying,
"Well, what's a mole?"
Well I encourage you to watch the video on
what a mole is, but a mole is a quantity.
It's like saying, "a dozen."
But it's a much larger, a dozen is equal
to 12 of something.
A mole is roughly equal
to, let me write it.
A mole is approximately equal to
6.02 times ten to the 23rd.
Ten to the 23rd of something.
And you're typically
talking about molecules.
A mole of a substance means approximately
6.022, it actually keeps going, times
ten to the 23rd molecules of that thing.
So you might say, "Hey, one
times ten to the negative seven
"times 6.02 times ten to the 23rd,
"that would still get
us," well let's see, this,
let me actually, let me write it down.
One times ten to the negative seven
moles per liter, times,
times, I'll do it this way.
Times six, I'll just go
with six, since we're
gonna go approximately.
So approximately, six
times ten to the 23rd.
Six times 23rd molecules,
molecules per mole.
Molecules per mole, well these two would
cancel out, and you would
multiply these two numbers,
you would get six times, let's see.
Ten to the negtive seven
times ten to the 23rd,
that's still gonna be
ten to the 16th power,
molecules per liter.
Molecules per liter, so
your first reaction is,
"Oh my God!"
"I'm gonna have six times,"
or roughly, I'll say roughly.
"Approximately six times ten to the 16th
"molecules of hydronium in this?"
"That's a lot, we should
see it all the time."
But we have to remind ourselves.
There's just a lot of molecules
of water in there as well.
In fact, a liter of water is roughly,
so one liter of H two O, contains,
contains approximately 56,
56 moles, moles of H two O.
So one way to think about it is,
"I have one, I have one times," and if I'm
thinking about a liter of water,
I have, I'll do it over here,
"I have one times ten
to the negative seven
"moles of, moles of H three O for every,
"for every 56 moles, for every 56 moles,
"moles of H two O."
So if you look at this ratio,
then you start to appreciate.
The ratio of one times ten
to the negative seven to 56.
Let me do it down here.
So this is the same thing as,
one times ten to the negative seven to 56,
is the same thing as,
let's just multiply both
side times, or the numerator
and the denominator,
times ten to the seventh.
So if we do that, this
is the same thing as one,
one, the ratio of
hydronium to regular water,
to H two O is gonna be one
to, let's see if I multiply
56, times ten to the
seventh, I'm gonna have
five, let me get, write
in that same color.
I'm gonna have five six,
then I'm gonna have,
I'm gonna throw seven
zeros at the end of it.
Let me do that.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
So the ratio of hydronium
to regular H two O
is one for ever five
hundred and sixty million.
So even though you might
say, "Oh wow, look."
"We're gonna have a
huge number of molecules
"of hydronium in this liter of water."
For every one of them, you actually have
roughly five hundred sixty
million molecules of H two O.
So that should give you
an appreciation for the
fact that this isn't that typical.
In fact, you're gonna
see this much more often
than you see this over here.
In fact, if you wanted
to make these arrows
kind of show which direction
the equilibrium sits in,
it's actually much further,
it's actually much further
to the left.
So we could make this arrow much bigger.
But it also gives you an appreciation
for just how many
molecules you have sitting
in a liter, in a liter of water.